have you ever been immobilized in the
face of a technical challenge in your
business or felt the need for a solution
that could help reduce your capital
investment in it
how about the ever evolving security
realm does it worry you a bit if yes
what are you doing about it believe it
or not these and many more i.t related
issues can be easily tackled with the
help of amazon web services or aws
but the question is how do you get to
know everything about them
well the aws technical essentials course
assists and empowers you in identifying
the best possible solution from the
amazon web services don't believe that
check out this conversation between
kevin hall the i.t head at dream people
llc and susan mitchell a database
administrator
hello susan i'm kevin hall we had met at
the tech conference in austin last week
remember
oh hi kevin yes i do
if i recall correctly you told me there
was some technical issue in your office
that was bothering you
right
actually i work in an hr payroll
processing company and we're facing a
peculiar problem at the end of each
month we see a peak in usage of our
applications leading to the application
slowing down as there are limitations in
the system architecture and the data
center
we heard that the cloud can help
increase application flexibility and
scalability however i'm unsure about
which cloud service provider to contact
also there is a deluge of information
out there i really don't know where to
get proper guidance to address this need
kevin recently a friend of mine told me
he had faced significant data storage
issues at work and after a bit of
research his company went ahead with
amazon web services as a matter of fact
he even suggested that i should do some
more research on my own before i decided
to use aws services and you know to my
surprise i realized that with aws we can
demand the power to manage storage and
related computer services from anywhere
aws provides us with the flexibility to
choose the development platform and the
programming model as we require and all
this is done in minutes along with all
this the infrastructure will have the
options to choose the development
platform or programming model specific
to their requirement
that sounds good but my problem is that
i want to know everything there is to
know about them before i share the
solution with my managers you see
they'll want to know every minute detail
and i need to be able to give it to them
i think i have the answer to that little
problem
why don't you join their technical
essentials course that way apart from
solving the present problem you'll be
able to guide them in the future too
so what's this course about
my friend told me that the aws technical
essentials course teaches you all that
you want to know about aws
wow susan
you seem to have given me the perfect
solution i'm feeling pretty confident
now about what i should do next thanks a
ton
there you go susan has managed to assist
kevin now in the following few screens
we will learn more about aws some of its
interesting facts key features market
trends for professionals and
organizations and how you can use aws
for free
aws is a reliable and secure cloud
computing platform offered by online
retail giant amazon it offers a set of
remote computing services with
competencies such as devops mobile
services security digital media
e-commerce big data
storage healthcare and microsoft sap and
oracle workloads
when compared to the traditional
computing landscape what sets aws apart
is its flexibility which allows an
organization to employ a mix of
architectures that work best for them
cost effectiveness where enterprises
only pay for what they use
scalability and elasticity enabling
savings and yielding better roi with
less friction end-to-end security
thorough certifications and
accreditations and experience evident in
its infrastructure built on lessons
picked up from amazon's 16-year journey
of delivering secure and reliable
solutions for large-scale global
infrastructure
if you are new to aws or are a sysop
administrator or developer or even
someone who is responsible for
articulating the business benefits of
aws services the aws technical
essentials course will not only
introduce you to these features and
benefits but even enable you to select
the perfect option for programming
models operating systems databases and
architectures
organizations can take advantage of the
reliability security and levels of scale
aws offers with its infrastructure build
leveraging amazon's experience managing
a global ecommerce platform for nearly
two decades
the depth and breadth of aws is amazing
comprising more than 48 services in
dozens of data centers located in 11
regions throughout the globe they offer
computing storage networking deployment
management and many supporting services
such as email and queues
it is quite likely that aws has more
than enough to help organizations and
individuals work smarter faster and more
cost effectively
a case in point is that of a leading
space agency capturing space capturing
space is a company that works on
earth-based projects
their projects vary from an exploration
of the arctic climate to robotic
articulation calculations however they
were experiencing difficulties as they
needed to share huge complex data sets
between users
employees who had participated in the
aws technical essentials course and were
familiar with the on-demand elastic
scalability of amazon web services were
asked to come up with a solution
now a scientist in toronto can work with
data and then those findings and the
data are instantly ready for a scientist
in toulouse
this course will help you comprehend all
choices that come with on-premises data
centers that are available and the
variety of choices they provide
organizations can opt to use their
on-premises data centers easily with aws
individuals taking this course will
understand that aws is ideal for those
working on small budgets but facing
constantly changing market trends
building new applications and upgrading
increasing capacity as per the growing
workloads
from launching complete oracle
enterprise software stacks in the cloud
to offering scalable low-cost secure
retailing solutions for businesses the
benefits of aws are plenty
they are used by enterprises for
virtually running any workload apart
from these aws offers security measures
as a potential customer if you know all
about what they have to offer you can
make the most appropriate decision
regarding your typical business
challenge
this is where the aws technical
essentials course comes into the picture
it introduces you to the entire range of
aws products services and common
solutions with demos knowledge checks
and hand on lab activities
the course strives to provide learners
with the basics to become adept in aws
and empowers them to make informed
decisions about i2 solutions based on
individual business requirements
according to the forbes magazine there
are 3.9 million jobs in the usa that are
affiliated with cloud computing
out of which the number of i.t related
cloud computing jobs are 384 478
it may interest you to know that
globally there are 18 million 239
258 cloud computing jobs and the median
salary for it professionals with cloud
computing experience is ninety thousand
nine hundred and fifty dollars and the
median salary for positions that pay
over one hundred thousand dollars a year
is one hundred and sixteen thousand nine
hundred and fifty dollars
we are witnessing a great jump in demand
for amazon web services around the globe
therefore it is essential that it
professionals update their knowledge by
enrolling for aws tech essentials to
improve their job prospects and work in
an environment where technical knowledge
of aws cloud services is the need of the
hour
aws technical essential certification
training from simplylearn is designed to
ensure that it technical end users
become completely conversant with the
essentials of the aws platform or the
management console
highly empowered in identifying
appropriate aws services that can help
them make informed decisions about it
solutions based on any business
requirements
and knowledgeable about aws security
measures storage options and manage
services and database options
this course is simply learns preparation
material for aws technical essentials
exam
and it will help you understand the
basic concepts related to cloud
computing
the course comprises 16 hours of
instructor-led training seven hours of
e-learning and most importantly provides
hands-on experience using the aws
management console and the related
amazon products
the course breakup is as follows
introduction to cloud computing
introduction and history to aws
aws storage and content delivery
compute services and networking
aws managed services and database and
deployment and management
instruction will entail the use of a
host of methods and strategies
the possible question types in the aws
technical essentials course exam include
multiple choice questions case studies
drag and drop and repeated answer
choices
however it is important to note that the
question types are not restricted to the
mentioned list
to help you prepare for the exam
simplylearn offers you two question sets
comprising of 60 questions each
this concludes the course introduction
the next lesson is introduction to cloud
computing wishing you all the best for
this course happy learning